osmond Khan and his gang here under
security surveillance in 2010 they were
plotting to blow up the London Stock
Exchange and to build a terrorist
training camp in Pakistan when he was
convicted at would its Crown Court in
2012 the judge said Khan and his
co-defendants had an ambitious and
serious jihadist agenda he added in my
judgement these offenders would remain
even after a lengthy term of
imprisonment of such significant risk
that the public could not be adequately
protected by their being managed on
licence in the community enough
expertise exists anymore to put support
measures and to monitor deceptive
natured individuals like Grossmann Khan
so what happened in February 2012 Khan
was given a sentence called
indeterminate for public protection
meaning he can't come out unless deemed
safe but amid fears they were being
misused IPPs was scrapped in December
2012 leading to many appeals against
them in April 2013 Khan went to the
court of appeal and was successful in
swapping his term to a determinate
sentence of 16 years under law at that
time he only needed to serve half his
sentence and did not require a parole
board to be released so he came out at
the end of 2018 on an electronic tag so
now comes the political argument I have
long said that this system simply isn't
working it does not make sense for us as
a society to video putting terrorists
people who've convicted of terrorist
offences of serious violent offences out
on early release but it was the
conservative coalition who ended
Labour's indeterminate sentences I think
we need to look at that what happens in
the in the prisons what happens with the
probation service and what happens with
the role of the parole board in this six
months after his conviction Khan wrote a
letter while in prison asking to go on
Adi radicalization program because he
wanted to become a good British citizen
it seems unlikely he was genuine and
this case poses a number of serious
questions this is why risk 7 the ability
to determine risk at the point of
sentencing
does the judge have access to all the
information the judge needs including
potentially secret intelligence secondly
calculation of risk at the point of
release and there may be difficult
issues for mi5 in counterterrorism
police to share intelligence that they
have with the parole board
but there are tricky issues here because
if someone's been in prison for a long
time it may be the amount of
intelligence that the authorities hold
one individual is relatively low because
they will they've been in prison
others say issues around sentencing are
a distraction from bigger issues the
current count extremism approach is very
broad and what I'm saying is that I
think that where the gap lies is the
fact that we are not doing enough to
counter the hateful ideologies that
independe the motivations for many of
these people who are either inspired to
carry out terrorist attacks or engage in
other forms of extremist behavior in our
country and the lessons from how Conn
went from jailed terrorists to someone
able to kill may well impact on those
still behind bars do to be released
Jason Farrell Sky News